für mein empfinden mit große gewalttätig
können was heißt das denn deutschland
gemeinsam machen es aber keinen satz
dieses geduzt macht mich hier
wird gesungen ja
hörte davon
sehr sehr heimlich
und der erste gedanke den man natürlich
hat ist
was diesem land möchten wir eher aus
warnt
erde war
[Musik]
eigentlich
und gemeinden ist ja auch alles sehr
ernst da ist ja keine spur vom sonntag
gewinnt richtig an kraft noch die kraft
der deutschen volks wieder
sehr gut damit hat man mich damit
in die cdu mehr mit bootsbauern
gearbeitet hätte
die wichtigen sachen lasst sie uns
machen und zu klein ist dieses land hat
doch so klein zu 35 konflikten wie da
sonst war ja auch drehen sowie soja beim
grillen bis natürlich ja
schon recht bestürzen ist eigentlich in
allen spots bestürzend wie wenig
konflikte gewagt
wir sind bereit
[Musik]
jetzt machen die grünen diesen
provokanten wahlwerbespot
und dann kommen wir zu der stelle wo
armin laschet sagt jetzt nicht in dem
spot wir sind uns einig es gibt so viel
dass uns vereint
und dann kommt fußball
bitte lassen sie uns den mantel des
schweigens darüber breiten ich gucke mir
auch nicht noch mal an dieses lied das
die das singen summen oder brunnen ein
solcher ohrwurm ist dass ich diesen spot
eigentlich als körperverletzung
empfinden muss länger kommt mir nicht
mehr aus dem sinn
und wenn man sich diesen spot genauer
anschauten genauer bett geht hat er
sogar was im namen gewalttätig ist in
der art und weise wird nämlich
widersprüche in den raum hinein zwingt
wie er die diversität der gesellschaft
dazu bringt ein
ziemlich abgenudelt das volkslied
zusammen zu singen und wenn ich von den
grünen nichts wusste außer diesem spot
dann würde ich sie für die furchtbarste
partei wie ich jemals zur wahl stand
halten
ja also mantel des schweigens nicht noch
mal gucken nicht mehr weiter sagen